[Music]
welcome one and all to the h3 podcast
experience like that we're experienced
now yeah I like it
the echo still it would be cool if you I
don't know if that's an effect or if you
guys could just do that with your voice
to be way cooler we can't hit hit us
down so you want to hit us with an
experienced healer hate to say h3
podcast oh it's only you sorry I got it
so already it's an ego thing he's got
you've got homie I have it I don't have
it and now it's gone anyway guys welcome
to the experience
today's sponsors are expressvpn and
honey and today's guest is the great and
hilarious comedian and actor Chris
D'Elia yes who hosts an extremely funny
podcast you should all be watching
called congratulations with Chris D'Elia
with me with you no guests you guys can
check him out
he's got you got yes talking about you
break I'm gonna cool you he's got it's
like I'm bring him out he's got the
Follow the Leader tour tickets are
available now at Chris D'Elia calm / -
or tour
also if you have Netflix and you have
not washes - hilarious specials manna
fire and incorrigibles then what the
[ __ ] are you doing with your life we can
curse here okay
I hope you have a full life if you
haven't seen them I hope you have a full
life in us cuz you've been so busy
you've been
yeah yeah that's the only accepted yeah
then I'm like all right cool yeah you
know but if not then hey maybe I'm just
not your type maybe I look like a guy
try it at least yeah true nothing did
you already have enough yes everybody
you know we talked about this recently
[ __ ] I think they almost have 200
million people on Netflix out it's like
over half the country so I did I know
yeah it's crazy so I did like a year and
a half ago they had a party for a
hundred million subscribers I was half a
year ago no a year like a year and a
half ago oh my god they're growing that
and and they were like they they hit my
manager and they were like just Chris
want to perform for the party I was like
no it's gonna be a [ __ ] train wreck
but I was like yeah I'm not gonna say no
what's your hesitation
you're performing to just the Netflix it
was like hey well it yeah and friends
and people that were invited to the
party it's a special event but it's just
like it's just I knew just any time as a
comedian that people are like you want
to perform it this thing that's not in a
comedy club right you're like okay so
I'm not gonna be right it's not gonna be
amazing you know but so so I was like
why I don't wanna say no to them and I
love Netflix so and I work for them so I
was like yeah I'll [ __ ] do it you
know and we made a fun it was fun it was
me and three other comedians cannot
remember who one of the other comedians
were that's how it was a crazy yeah but
it was it was it was fun we made it fun
it was like in this room off to the side
where other bands were playing to so we
like you heard your yeah crazy was like
knows how to party I know how they do it
was huge it was huge and we were doing
it was like it brought them back to the
Open Mic days when I was doing like I
would play bowling alleys that doesn't
sound nice I mean dude you play I play I
play bowling alleys that where like you
would compete with people who were
bowling in between pants at a time like
the punish line in between like after
they are right before they it would go
quit the business is that the worst show
you've ever done you know the bowling
alley
no no what's the worst I ever did I
talked about it and incorrigible is when
well the worst kind of like show coming
up that I did was where a lady rushed
the stage and it was because she was
heckling me and I said to her she had
like this really like wild hair that was
like really up and out and I and I
called her Blanca after she was like you
know faithful fighter yeah course I do
and she I was like I don't even know
she's gonna know what this means and I
did and she knew what it meant she was
very she or Ana right up and grabbed the
microphone well hit my face I pushed it
into my face and I was like oh god I
gotta say of all of the insults that
would cause someone to attack you the
Street Fighter reference yeah pretty
special one it's a good one and it just
kind of proved my point because I feel
like that's kind of
Blanka would have done get you some of
those sparks ya-ya-ya-ya-ya likes to get
you fast oh yeah
meeting my it was that one where he ate
the guy's head right of course
hey whatever she would have done that
yeah are you we I realize we've been
podcasting for about the same really
time because you this is what episode is
the monney 70 71 71 so I'm on like I
think I'm on 74 so yeah in about three
weeks or yeah three week different I'm
curious how is podcasting like affected
your stand-up in a way yeah it kind of
it's been really actually it's been
really interesting because I you know I
started a podcast after I had a
following right right and yeah would you
guys did too so and and I did so I was
like look I'm just gonna do this and see
how long it lasts you know everyone's
got a part I felt like you know I really
found out through other comedians that
if you don't have a podcast and you
already have a fanbase you're leaving
money on the table
yeah so also beyond that it's just a
great way to connect but I didn't think
of it that way until I started doing it
I was like you know I was like oh no I
want to make money more money and [ __ ]
it you know and then and then I realized
once I started doing it how much like I
mean in a much smaller way for me at
least it's like you know it's like a TV
like the TV SH the when you when people
are watching a TV show and they're like
I gotta wait till next week to watch the
next evey show which we a lot of the
little binge watch now but when I was a
kid that's how people used to watch TV
and now people feel connected and they
wait for the you know they feel like
they know me more yeah most and they do
yeah because I'm you know me or a
version of me on that comedy comedy
podcast you know and but yeah it really
like makes them feel like they know you
and that's kind of a double-edged sword
sometimes you like in sometimes you
don't but but but it it it as as I might
have my opener when he says you guys
listen to congratulations before he
brings me up the cheers have just gotten
bigger and bigger bigger throughout the
whole past year yeah it's really crazy
it's really crazy your podcast is
different than ours
that you're just it's you and you're
talking I mean how was that experience
from going from stand-up to just like
talking into a camera and nobody's there
cuz you do shows you act a lot right but
was that a different skill to learn or
did it kind of translate I you know what
it's it's it's like stayin up in the way
that like stand up to me is a version of
making like when I'm at a diner with my
friends late night I'm sometimes like
you know doing jokes I mean we're always
joking around messing around but like
sometimes I'm just [ __ ] with them and
we're just making jokes and we're doing
bits or whatever I always felt like
before I did stand-up I was like if I
could get to be onstage and treat the
audience like they're the other people
in the diner then I'll be able to do I
know I'll be able to do it because I'd
literally would do that every day of my
life I'm obsessed with trying to may be
able laugh and like trying to and and
and think about what do I think it's
funny what's funny about this situation
and so for podcasting it was the same
thing except it except like it when I'm
in my house and I'm with my dogs like
I'll catch myself just like talking
about things for no reason like I'm a
[ __ ] insane person and then and then
I'm like oh maybe I'll say that on my mi
in my show or my act or whatever but
then when I started to do the podcast I
was like oh this is just that this is
just like me talking out loud in my
house yeah and I kind of do that anyway
I don't do a probable hour like I'm an
insane person but like that's how I come
up with material I just start like
talking in my house and I uh I think oh
that's funny and giver this is material
born from your podcast ever does
anything start and the podcast and then
goes - yeah it has for sure yeah yeah
that's awesome yeah I did yeah well it
also helps me like creatively because I
don't like sit down and like write at
the computer my hack so like yeah
because when you do your act is it very
much rehearsed mmm for me I'll go up
with an idea that I have and when you do
man on fire yeah just like yeah yeah
well that's that's the act that I've
been kind of honing right okay right but
all obeah but all of those bits came
from
me going on stage thinking like oh it's
funny when guys work out I'll go on
stage and start talking about it that's
mom that's a wild way to approach it to
kind of just go up there and be like
alright let's see what's yeah I mean I
think I think though like so much of it
is about like that's what I say if I go
back going back to like being in a diner
with my friends I'm so comfortable with
them they're my friend this time do you
know what I mean yeah and and I think
through years and years of practice and
through the thousands and thousands of
shows yeah
I'm able to get into that headspace
onstage you know that's awesome
so I and I love it I love doing it and
it's you know it there's an old saying
like it's not what you say it's how you
say it
and and you know I think it is if you're
that confident and I mean like there's
guys who my buddy Bryan Callen it goes
onstage she talks about horseshit for an
hour and it's hilarious yeah and it's
not true but he acts like it is and it's
it's you know yeah so it's those guys
were the I mean you know guys like that
just it's about how you say it that's
cool
I think that's a cool way to just hone
the skill just get in the [ __ ]
gauntlet and yeah and get it down and
it's a one time dude one time I was on a
plane I [ __ ] you not man if somebody
told me this I wouldn't have I wouldn't
believe that but it happened to me and I
know it happened to me and it's true
because I know that because I witnessed
it this almost sounds like a lie yeah I
know part of it is because I have to I
have to convince myself it actually huh
okay it's it's not nobody's [ __ ] on the
plane or anything like that but it's
like so I'm we're gonna Montreal which
is a big festival in Montreal Just for
Laughs I'm doing it again this year but
I went and they fly us up there and
whenever you fly up there since it's a
stand up festival it's comedy festival
there's always like nine comedians on
your flight right she's sitting there
with you know Sebastian Tom Segura bill
burr whoever the [ __ ] and you see a
Chelsea Handler oh hey you know so Adam
Carolla's sitting behind me I know I
know Adam you know I say hey he sits
behind me and he doesn't know there's
another comedian behind me and I meet
him and
Adam didn't know him so Adam Carolla is
sitting next to this other comedian this
is the two seats I'm in front of him and
the flight to Montreal from LAX is six
hours okay and Adam Carolla
I'm telling you did not stop talking to
that kid for longer than no exaggeration
30 seconds now you were watching this
with like more of a curiosity in the
beginning I was like and I kind I know
Adam and I loved at him and he's great
at those pockets all the time and and
he's [ __ ] hilarious
and I was like when's this guy gonna
freakin take a break yeah dude
he he didn't he didn't take a break he
didn't take a break the other kid didn't
talk it was just like yeah yeah and then
first hour I was like man he's bent over
an hour and I'm [ __ ] magic and I was
like I'm gonna I'm gonna stay listening
because I have to I have to find out
when he takes a break right I have to
like see how long and he didn't
dude land he landed and I was like this
[ __ ] and was he talking off the
plane it kept going yeah he never
stopped he never signed a kid the new
kid who was on the road you know who
that was hey did you catch a glance in
his eye no no not while it was going on
maybe I did I was there was anything
interesting you know every was all
interesting that's something Adam
Carolla is so good at that and he was
talking about stuff and I was like man
this guy's did it's like he had thought
about everything already that ever
happened right and he's like if you say
target if the guys like yeah q-tips is
like well you know guys just amazing at
it so so when you're in that comfortable
space where you can just I'm saying like
Corolla didn't even need that kid to be
sitting there okay and it was
interesting if you just talk for six
hours I could be like alright I would
listen yes he's a conduit of comedy yeah
it's always challenge so you know and
I'm not saying I'm as good as that but I
you know to get into that comfortable
space to where you can just talk which
is what we do as comedians so I feel
like it was a version of that and I just
had to work through a few episodes and
then I kind of I think figured it out
after like the third episode I was like
oh I can do I really expected to do
about three or four episodes
and then just chalk it up as a as a loss
but well guys check it out
74 now so we'll keep going god bless
imma listen so I want I know you've
probably talked about this so many times
but we've talked about on the podcast
yeah and Logan Paul yeah hit me with
that echo Logan Paul alright we missed
Logan Paul shot it because we got that
he's he's something we've talked about a
lot oh yeah yeah yeah I saw you guys
sell and we talked about it and it's
like he's I feel like that exchange
really showed what a [ __ ] dumb ass he
is or maybe even just like how damaged
he is from the hole yeah suicide forest
yeah I want to go over it with yeah yeah
if you don't mom happy - yeah I want to
go over this and and I want to get your
thoughts on some of these twitter
exchanges okay yeah well first of all
I'm curious your initial interaction
when he said it's important that you
want right no it's not right now how did
Logan Paul come on your radar to begin
with because you were following you are
ready yeah I don't know if I was fault I
may have been following him but I think
actually I just maybe saw it because
he's so dumb you know what I mean yeah
so I probably just responded to it maybe
I follow him I don't know but so I just
write no it wasn't because because of
the suicide forest yeah great that
wasn't yeah and how everywhere that was
yeah that well yeah that was just bad
but and so I just wrote no it wasn't
because like a shot of dead body in the
forest land this is important man no
wasn't so it's less I was trolling him
and more that I was just reacting off of
that right and I just thought I didn't
think anything of it I just yeah it's
and then but when he responded and let
me pull this up actually because this
was like damn dog really [ __ ] try to
make this work the tsunami of Brian yeah
[ __ ] like what did you think when you
saw that wave of yellow and blue I was
really confused because I thought it was
a fake I was like this is not him I saw
the check yeah I was like okay so I
guess that is
and then I thought that's so many emoji
he's so [ __ ] amused yeah like that's
laughing for a long time that's not that
yeah that's like it's not funny anymore
yeah that's like the first two rows it's
getting a little sad yeah yeah yeah
after two rows you're like oh [ __ ] man
maybe he's just mentally imbalanced
because that's why he thought it was
okay to shoot somebody and then when he
said and then I read it wrong I first
read it I'm laughing because I know why
your comedy career took a dive and not I
didn't read I'm laughing because now I
know why you're coming so I thought he
knew something I didn't know and I was
like this is Garrison what did I do that
I don't know that's bad right that's
that's so much about me like I'm like
did I do something like my head is like
because it's such a stupid comment you
almost want to believe that it's like oh
my god does he actually know is there
something else right like yeah yeah like
did he send me your illiterate person
first response then no it's not was so
not like deserving of anything more than
just just just Leon just yeah just like
a [ __ ] off or whatever the [ __ ] it's so
personally like with that response yeah
also what is it in your response that
you know educated him so now what like
why your comedy career took a dive like
there wasn't that much information
encoded my initial response right yeah
yes is that now I know because I wasn't
trying to make a joke yeah just like
saying something yeah we saw that that's
it that's I guess like in comedy like
you'd say what he did was fundamentally
flawed right but another thing that's
fundamentally and I was listening to
Bert Kreischer talk about this too and
and this sounds defensive and this is
why I have not said this until now my
comedy career has not taken a dive right
it's it everyone's been more and more
clearly a wounded child but what Bert
was saying and he's right there needs to
be some kind of true
in your burn or roast or spam what if
you want to call it so I was like oh I
was like oh and so I read all that and
then I read it correctly it's like I'm
laughing because I knew why I now I know
why you're coming to her
oh yeah he's trying to act like I was
trying to joking with him yeah so then
I'm kind of I I honestly went right to
feeling badly right because I was like
well you might have realized you're
dealing with a child but well he's 24
though right
but that intellectually like how can you
write that and not have the intellect of
a much younger person that's true but
even further than that here's here's the
thing like if you're gonna write to
somebody who I write to people oh dude
this is fun for me
right I like to [ __ ] clap back and
[ __ ] like that yes to me I'm bored and
people are like why do you take it
personally I don't it's just fun I like
doing it my whole thing is if you say
something to me and you got your 14
followers and you think nobody's gonna
see it dude I can't wait I can't I want
to imagine the look on your face when I
read you this is your game really I I
love that philosophy so fun
yeah people don't appreciate the [ __ ]
that you get when you're online like oh
Jesus Christ and I love when you do that
they get mad at you like you should have
known better
yeah but they're brilliant on black yes
yeah and it's like dude Oh waiter oh hey
this is the internet like welcome to the
[ __ ] Internet but it's like when you
sign up for Twitter isn't know what what
you dream happen that somebody gives you
attention like that's why you're here it
is you would just browse Twitter you
don't even need an account yeah exactly
so so then I kind of felt bad cuz I was
like damn I'm gonna I I knew exactly
what to say yeah yeah so that was like
what I said right Kofi he basically set
you up for a code I was like oh maybe I
maybe I should leave it alone but I
can't leave it alone because he kind of
took it to the next level maybe if there
was one row of class but then I was like
[ __ ] it I'm just gonna do it I did it
and I was like that's what you write
well at least my career dies you can
film it and put it on YouTube I love
that when you quote with him you can't
even I don't know either no way wouldn't
see the response that was such a slam
dunk like yes I mean and look at the
likes they're like on that one just like
everyone okay sorry
alright so he should have been like you
know well played
I'm gonna go on my dad yeah but he
should have known I was gonna say
something yeah but but here's the other
thing too like you're you're doing this
to somebody who's going to write back to
you who does this for a living yeah like
it's not it's not you're not doing it to
Jerry Seinfeld who's gonna be like who's
that kid oh yeah going right back to you
yeah and and this is what I do so like
anyway I did that let's see what's next
and then he just kept going not gonna
lie this single tweet is funnier than
your tired Netflix special which
actually has a lot of money back right
yeah yes and there was a lot is at least
technically breaking this down if I were
a dork you know it makes sense it's fun
compared to that yeah but he he admits
he saw my entire Netflix special right
he must not have hated it that much and
in a way in a way that's really a
sincere compliment cuz he's like I've
enjoyed your Netflix special enough to
watch the whole thing yes and this tweet
was banner and months ago that was great
but now you're even tired I almost let
it go because I couldn't because I
thought of this and I was like thanks
how does it feel to have your name
finally attached to something
you don't understand no good man and I'm
on my phone like I'm having fun because
come on yeah yeah come on so this is
something that Logan and his peers do a
lot what they do the little thing of
like the 38 year old it's like dog I
don't get that I mean ah yeah oh well
first of all I'm 38 I'm not I'm not
sixty yeah but right but that aside I
don't understand the whole your old you
don't get it thing because everyone gets
to be old I that's my favorite images
that Logan is not that young at the same
time guys hidden behind this guy's like
I'm just a kid for so long yeah yeah you
take that I find what I'm 38 yeah but
the thing is I had loved to imagine
Logan Paul 38 and he is gonna be
completely without hair he's gonna it's
gonna be a beautiful thing I want to
check in when he's 38 and then it's be
like talk you can't talk to anybody
anymore because you're 38 year old man
yeah I remember you said the thing I
have it on my calendar like 12 years
yeah I don't I don't know the the the
aid that's not a very good argument
because who [ __ ] yeah but also by its
merit there's nothing really insulting
about it no I just shows how immature he
is it's like you're 38 I should I don't
I don't what do I care about anything
you think also also imagine imagine
referring to yourself right as a shunned
it so it really do you have a
rock-bottom thing yeah like like that's
how he sees himself is kind of almost
like imagine being like yeah cuz you
know cause like I'm a son hey who are we
fighting against because we're both on
the same team here you're we're both
fighting you
the meeting with the spider-man in the
spider-man where they look at each other
that's what the [ __ ] he's doing right
now
well it's funny you didn't say shun
flogger no in Urdu not also is like
blaming you for our hearing with him
over Twitter when he was the one to to
make it into this whole thing as it's
been broken down this not like there's
so many layers yeah it's a lot I haven't
done it yet so funny that he used like a
night like I don't know what I don't
know it's worse he's [ __ ] a shunned or
lager or being the 38 oldest [ __ ] your
life is basically over comedian arguing
with and the insinuation the crux of
this is that anybody who interacts with
the shun vlogger like you're arguing
with the Shawn Hager over Twitter
yeah who argues on Twitter yeah who does
that
so so that prove it
deprecating in the worst way let's keep
going yeah you ask your fans to have
their mom I didn't want to make fun of
how young his fans were but I felt like
that because he brought up the age it
was coming age right yeah it's really
great yeah and I was like this is it
good enough to me I was like this is
funny enough to bring that up I just
didn't want to be like well yeah not
they're just young noannie and the truth
is if you ever do look up like fan
meetup photos like yeah it's pretty
shocking yeah can you look up pregnant
lady be like oh you're a fan no my baby
[Laughter]
anyone in it doesn't stop no but here's
the thing he I think and this may not be
right but I think he wanted to have the
last word but he didn't want me to see
it so that I wouldn't even oh oh
old people roasting me so I was like I
think I actually spawned it today well
I'm not sure what that the significance
of the greater than symbol is in this
situation old people greater than
greatest thing on planet earth and I
don't understand the significance right
oh well at any rate I love that he
that's a good observation that's
definitely what happened yeah I think so
yeah and you know he had like his whole
think tank well because he rolls with a
posse hello gang like to think that when
they were also at the suicide forest but
then why do I only come up with those
insults because yeah my friend they're
all I had other ones too that were so
brutal but I just do you remember any no
I don't I I think I was gonna have root
of one was that gonna go like I didn't
bring anybody else but him into it I was
good of you know what I mean but I was
just like me I can't do well you did it
basically how about this you're my son
like your [ __ ] daddy I'm your [ __ ]
dad this this way I was like at least
I'm now getting sillier I'm like are ya
you know I mean like I just wanted I
don't like cuz dude in my head like
maybe this kid I don't know him
maybe he's maybe he's literally like I'm
having fun making fun of the woods
comedian no I don't know no no I don't
in a way it's almost like a suicide
forest all over again
but you're the one filming the dead body
and it does it continue or we have Logan
go Oh Chris this whole exchange is
really really similar to your life as
time passes your jokes get less and less
funny sorry dad yeah that one actually
and the likes are getting us but also as
time passes jokes do get less and less
funny just because just by the
neighborhood as as time passes memories
become less get older you're 38 dude you
don't remember anything probably and I
don't know I think there might have been
a dive yeah this is one of the best dude
man thanks but I first of all I first of
all thank second of all I walked around
I walked around and people were like it
was like I did the [ __ ] Tonight Show
in 1987 right it speaks to how much and
how much they how much they cared about
that thing you did in the suicide forest
like like I get I listen
you know I get that what I said was you
know somewhat funny but that that isn't
why it got so many retweets it got so
many retweets because they felt
emotional about the stuff that he did it
was a beautiful perfect storm sadly your
new media is usually in mainstream media
only when something awful happens mm-hmm
and Logan that suicide forced him was
just so [ __ ] yeah but like I mean that
was this was a beautiful this was just a
perfect battle between good and evil it
played out on Twitter in this way age
and I and something occurred to me as I
read his final tweet then and in this
whole this whole suicide forest part -
mm-hm
this was the one this was the brain
trust final act this was what they all
thought about and we're like that's the
one oh right Chris this whole exchange
really soon because he's had a set up he
dramatically yes you know phase it out
this was this was it this this was their
joke this was the coup de Gras okay well
did they get yeah we are gonna take a
short break we will be right back with
the great and hilarious Chris D'Elia if
you go anywhere well I guess that's your
prerogative but I urge you to stay see
you soon
thank you to expressvpn for sponsoring
this episode guys if you are not using a
VPN in this day and age you're literally
insane you've got Facebook you've got
Twitter you've got Google you got all
these tech giants peeking up your skirt
skirt you've yes they're seeing the
goods and they're not paying for it
you've got you've got your own ISP right
they know everything you're doing the
VPN hide your activity and keeps you
anonymous and let's be frank the weird
[ __ ] that you're doing on the Internet
if that ever came out you'd your life
would be ruined and it just takes one
rogue guy with a VPN to be like oh look
what Ethan's been up to when it be a
ship - exactly I don't want you to know
and I don't ever want you to know and
that's the power
of the VPN it masks all your activity it
gets you anonymous as the Internet
should be that keeps you safe and it
keeps all these other employees from
peeping up your skirt without buying you
dinner
pound it here's another thing if you're
in a public space and you're not using a
VPN you are literally getting hacked by
everybody there you go into a Starbucks
there's 50 people there you know there's
at least one guy stealing people's
credit card information and bank
statements and all of your private
information without a VPN you are
subject to people literally stealing
your data in public spaces if you're not
using a VPN and today's age you are
literally nuts the best one is
expressvpn it's fast it's the world's
leader and security they keep your
activity private and anonymous they are
great for streaming with their blazing
blazing fast speeds and it cost less
than seven bucks a month give me a
frickin break I'd say that's a great
price to pay for a little on amenity
that's what the Internet's all about so
every time use internet without
expressvpn you are putting sensitive
data at risk
take your internet privacy back right
now and find out how you can get three
months free go to expressvpn calm /h
Street
that's expr ESS VPN comm / HD for three
months free with a one-year package
fidgets visit expressvpn dot-com / h3 to
learn more this is so important you guys
don't let it get out about the hentai
you've been watching thank you honey if
you're not using honey then you are
literally burning money right EULA it's
true honey is as good as it sounds sweet
as honey it's the honey pot folks just
put your hand in and get some of that
sweet honey honey is an app you install
it it's two clicks on the browser you're
using you shopped the web like you
usually do what this does is it checks
for coupons your yeah you ever you
neuron
like we are and you just you're like oh
I'm buying shoes let me just see if this
store has coupons on there because
sometimes you find the coop again 50%
off
honey does that for you while you shop
not only do they save you money they
save you life if you're like me because
I'm neurotic to the point I'll spend 30
minutes looking for a coupon you know
what I mean and then I'll go it's like
man I saved 20 bucks and I spent 30
minutes of my life I'm not sure it was
worth it honey saves you both
automatically with two fricking clicks
look here I was shopping for shoes swear
to God
got a couple pairs honey pops in at the
checkout and is like I found coupons
click here to apply it boom
look at this 53 dollars save without
even thinking about it I was skeptical
at first of honey I was like what's the
deal with this it frickin works and I
love it and I wouldn't browse without it
anymore also does she like on Amazon it
compares previous prices and sellers
like the best price
yeah it tells you if this is like the
best price it's ever been if you should
stick around if you should hold it or if
you should slam and that's the honeypot
folks when honey's got your back
you will never overpay for anything on
Amazon ever again they're gonna save you
money you're gonna be praising to the
Lord Jesus honey how could I ever done
it without you it's two clicks it's free
there's no reason not to add honey get
the sweetness get it in your mouth
you're gonna get the honey you're gonna
be like oh my god it's a little sticky
it's a little wild but it tastes so
effing good and it's free your base is
gonna be Winnie the frickin Pooh after
you plug this baby in
so go add it right freaking now join
honey calm / h3 that's join honey calm /
h3 it's free it takes two clicks you
have nothing to lose
give it a shot or my name isn't Pooh
Bear pretty cut that part down
we are back with Chris D'Elia what's the
[ __ ] deal with Lacroix alright yeah
and I know I know the day that I learned
about Lacroix and I and it's weird that
I'm telling you this now because you'd
brought this up he so you guys brought
up that you didn't know or they didn't
realize I was on an episode of
workaholics and before I kind of had
Topher a fan that garea greatest
workaholics episode ever sing the praise
it was our favorite episode and out up
wow thanks that's that's that that's
that's the one well thanks anyway
at any rate it was the first season of
the shove the show and while I was
shooting that as Topher that was when I
learned when you had your first the
Blake was like man lacroix is [ __ ]
awesome he would simply add thing yeah
like what is this [ __ ] and I was [ __ ]
soda
I don't really good it is better than
here's what I here's my thing about
Lacroix they and there's not an ad no
this is not a but everybody [ __ ]
knows what Lacroix is yeah it's like
people which is just like it's the
Google of notarizing but everyone know
why is it that people act as if Lacroix
invented soda we are you could buy soda
water yes a little flavor always always
was when I came out of my male vers
everything that they offered you a sip
of cherry flavored so know what it is so
why is it what is it like French it's
got a French name but I heard that in
our life we didn't Tom tell it's not was
saying it's a gross like yeah the crew
or some [ __ ] I don't know and he was
getting upset cuz it was like you guys
aren't the guys in May who named it he
was saying they wanted to be called like
Lacroix like the French way but it's
like but you guys are not French so it's
like how the [ __ ] is a pro know this
surprised I was like oh [ __ ] you speak
French like no but um and all about
drinks I think what they did is like
it's an American friend kids were not
drinking soda water was the beverage of
of your dad I always hated it
yeah me too me too and and I think it
was a perfect timing of people being
like maybe I don't want to drink 50
grams of sugar mm-hmm but I want
something more exciting than water
you're right none the GAR that yeah
before I was born
believe this isn't an had but especially
well let me just say to equal this out
it's [ __ ] soda water my 99-cent Ralph
or and soda water through the same [ __ ]
not the thing but here's the thing I
don't like I think sparkling water I
don't like it as bright as I don't like
it as much as club soda
I like club sort of better that is the
point soda oh I didn't know there was a
distinction if you're sure fuel I'm
holding it like this like okay they need
to pay me now I'm gonna put it down club
soda has has a larger bubble it feels
like it like like whenever it like I'm
in a restaurant I'm like can I get club
soda and they're like you want
Pellegrino I'm like nah do you have it
from the gun that I [ __ ] yeah exactly
so did I [ __ ] stutter I've heard you
know I've hung out with friends who are
like mmm
oh the difference yeah yeah they're like
I'll I prefer Pellegrino because it has
tighter bubbles oh yeah really it does
huh so the carbonation is less intense
yes is that the difference it's like
fine and the club is like if you chug it
you'll [ __ ] your throat up yeah thank
you
that's why I love that [ __ ] a little
burn I love it nice because when I I was
like 31 and my I did a I was actually
doing some kind of a joke with my family
and I lifted my shirt up as it Ford the
joke and my mom was like you gained some
weight and I was like knowing I had been
175 my whole life and 175 yeah they're
tall guys that's pretty well but this
was when I was 31 and so I was like
knowledge is like I have a scale up
there weren't you wave something I was
195 and I almost passed out I was like
oh my god I'm torn upon severe I didn't
check mmm this long and but I'm tall so
like it down yeah you know and and I
stopped drinking soda I started drinking
diet at first I and I [ __ ] hate diet
soda all of you stood I like it now I
never got used and televised a year I
was like dude this is its it tastes
horrible
at first it tastes like you know poison
really
but it is yeah the thing is when I
presented what the choice of do I want
the original or do I want the back
basically it's do I want to be fat or
don't want to die of cancer diabetes or
cancer it's literally the what you're
choosing and so so III scrape I was like
diabetes never tastes so good so I would
like at least I look good right hold
life all right
even though it will be shorter yeah
and that is basically if I'm I ever run
for mayor that's what I'm gonna use as
my platform do you know what I mean like
live a shorter life but look good the
whole time
and as mayor you're somebody diet yes if
they pay me and so so I I stopped
drinking diet so I was like [ __ ] this
diet this sucks - right and so and then
I would watch like the documentaries
about how as I die
and so I I started I was like [ __ ] this
and I started drinking just water and I
was like I can't just drink [ __ ] yeah
what am I we're human beings we crave
yeah this is why we're on this earth we
invented things better than water yeah
come on that's like saying I'm not gonna
live in a house I'm just gonna go
camping I'm gonna live in a [ __ ] cave
that's all yeah
get the [ __ ] out of here we made walls
we got toasters and microwaves let's do
all of those [ __ ] so now and so
now I'm like alright I'm not gonna just
drink water and then I was like let's
see what this [ __ ] Lacroix is up
right and I did and it was the I waited
enough time to where I didn't have the
disso de and I was like oh this has the
bubbles but also it's not just water low
flavor a little flavor if you want that
flavor by the way what what's the flavor
that I drink where does it come for I
don't know is that we didn't yeah but I
also drink the regular blue Lacroix I'll
just drink regular sort of walk just
straight that's safe yeah cuz we know
what the bubbles are but like they're
like I mean I think about how this is
kind of weird right they're like here's
a mango flavored soda water yeah there's
just as well no mango and you look at
the [ __ ] thing
and zero oh no a manual but if you eat a
mango it's not zero across I'm just
saying maybe just I'm glad this isn't an
ad cuz my boy your [ __ ] for doing it
is from Wisconsin this is from Wisconsin
yeah you can tell people from Wisconsin
look Roy may well be making millions
people cancer true yeah we wouldn't know
now it just came out ten fine down in
ten years to be like yeah it turns out
that little kroy's the new smoking in in
in 30 years I'm gonna be like on a
hospital bed just like I shouldn't have
drank all that look cry sugar was
organic damn it we understood what it
was at least now they can take the
cancer out they can take the sugar
cancer out that can't take the look cry
well guys if your drink Lacroix
responsibly and be aware you know you
could be cost something it could cost a
new disease that we didn't even have yet
that's the thing about disease it's just
gonna keep we're gonna figure stuff out
and then I don't want papi common yeah
I'm also gonna run as mayor at that path
guys that's a killer platform literally
yeah you're all gonna die you might as
well have me be your memory so on
Twitter well clearly you know you got
into a slogan but you're very you have a
good time on Twitter Lindsay you have a
trend where you if people talk some
smack yeah your reque-- time on blast
into the world yeah but I'm curious this
Twitter comments ever like actually get
to you because sometimes you know in my
case yeah sometimes you know it's it's a
lot yeah like do they ever make me feel
bad like it's something like about a
performance or a stand-up or whatever
like hey I don't I don't I didn't like
what you did yeah if it's a genuine
thing and not just like yeah oh you know
you sucked a piece of [ __ ] or whatever
but if it's like I don't know though
I I mean me I can't say it never affects
me but like you know a person but like I
just I kind of the Internet is just like
you have to adopt the fact that it's
just Narnia and it doesn't exist or
you're gonna go [ __ ] crazy yeah you
know and my brother also told me some
when I was a kid when I was coming up
when I was growing up and he's younger
than me but we were talking about girls
and I was talking about how I hated when
a girl didn't like me and I liked her
like and I was like why does that bother
me so much nothing yeah it sucks I want
that I'd like to rejection you know yeah
and my brother said well what do you
think everybody's gonna like you and I
know that's so so simple but that time
for some reason it clicked like that
that isn't possible so I was like yeah
and it made it a lot easier so now I'm
telling you that was like a switch and I
know it's so simple and I'm not an idiot
I did that already
how the brain was ready yeah just like
it was like a perfect time yeah perfect
waited that he said it and it was just
like yeah I guess [ __ ] it you know plus
stand up when you're on stage telling
400 people a joke and it bombs right you
tend to learn to not care about is that
the worst thing follow me on stage to
this day are you does that happen still
when you're like honestly when once you
have any sort of fan base it it's it
becomes tougher to bomb because people
just a very general thank you yeah more
generous like and they give you a better
fitted out I always say this though
you're not truly bombing a comedian
doesn't truly bomb unless the comedian
feels bad about bombing because you're
on stage it's all about the state of
money bomb bombing like if people aren't
laughing and I'm like I [ __ ] [ __ ] you
guys it doesn't matter this is funny
yeah you don't feel bad for the guy
right you're like guys he's just having
an off night but if I'm on stage I'm
bombing and he frankly not laughing and
I'm just like well anyway
see it then you're like oh this guy's so
well being on the stage is so much about
that confidence yeah which I I do I know
if we talk about this on air or off air
but we were talking about it before
maybe 20 minutes ago but yeah
yeah it's about it's how you say it and
yeah but it's still tough though
sometimes if if like you know if I get
heckle I get heckled a bunch and if if I
get heckled and and I dig a hole because
I'm like telling some guy off and then I
try to get back into it it's tougher and
I'll snap back yeah it happened the
other night actually um what'd he say
now you know what I get sometimes I hate
this who's like like mid Joe yeah
like woo like you're not at the [ __ ]
Mets game like laughing don't laugh but
if I'm like if I'm like hey so why was
that Verizon and someone's like hey like
you don't [ __ ] or like I mentioned
the other night I was like yeah I said
some about El Paso and somebody's I will
pass over and I'm like imagine being a
guy who does that
imagine being a guy who is like oh dude
that guy just said where I'm from and
then having to be like yeah that's
that's imagine being a guy who does that
and for real lots of guys do that that's
[ __ ] to me that's I'd rather be a guy
who like thought my own [ __ ] was his
meal that guy but to be one of those
douchebag guys that's like he said
[ __ ] Austin whoo like you suck and
you're also in this society I wonder if
he thinks he's helping you yeah because
then I roast them and then they're like
mid to show better right no man I would
I'm hilarious thank God I [ __ ] just
fixed it right so everyone's gonna be
worn at your show yeah but it's like
it's like it's like going to the [ __ ]
it's like going to Ikea and and
and that guy [ __ ] up the show and me
fixing it and thinking that he did it is
like as I go to Ikea and walking in with
the furniture and then breaking it and
going and then being like it broke
you're like alright well you broke it
you [ __ ] it up I've heard you going
rants like this similar I heard you
ranting recently about listening parties
yeah dude well the new thing this wasn't
a thing like a couple years this is lost
we are man dude okay so you made a you
made an album we can hear it anywhere do
you know that you know that okay so why
are we flying to Wyoming if you're not
gonna be doing it live we're just gonna
be around a fire and Kid Cudi's gonna be
there huh
eat my dick there's no [ __ ] way
there's no what makes you so angry that
I'm intrigued because you weren't
invited into that somebody said that
entrepreneurs like bro you don't know me
Kanye West [ __ ] knocked on my door
and said hey man you want to come to my
listening party I go like this hey man
no I will wait for this [ __ ] Spotify
thing to drop what is it that listening
to music was a bunch of people in a room
did it make you go [ __ ] nuts because
you know why because it because because
here's why because I'm 80 and that's a
[ __ ] small it might be more 80% of
the people are just there because it's a
thing that's right that's not because
they really want to hear down because if
you just really wanted to hear the album
you just hear the [ __ ] album right
yeah okay
you wouldn't cop a flight to Wyoming
alright so so that's really what it is
and that's what I have this thing on my
podcast where I talk about that's what a
[ __ ] CUDA is man and a CUDA is short
for Barracuda and a barracudas if you're
wearing jewelry and you and you fish and
they get a barracuda and you pull it
vertically
the Barracuda will attack you because it
sees jewelry and it's just like high
jewelry gotta have it that's what that's
what you are if you're going to
Coachella
that's what
doing he's like moths the thing let's go
do what you want
I've never been to either Coachella or
to listening party so it's just fun no
but last night I felt that oh my god
every every yeah everybody has a little
bit of CUDA in them right yeah you need
Markham you got here last night yeah you
need a little you need a little look
Lacroix in your life you need a simple
if you have to and I get it and to me my
life is all about fighting that as best
I can right now that's a valiant that's
a valiant war dude I have a code man
yeah do you know let me ask you this
what what about your about your shoes
what about my shoes they're not the Bell
if I do cheers yeah no I got these I was
I was do you think that's a little
because well wait those are Kanye's yeah
oh yeah so you won't go to a listening
party but you'll wear his [ __ ] go
anyway that ship I'm right here
I got him on stock ex I love shoes I'm
at in it in that way you can say but I
buy it I buy the shoes that I really
genuinely like I and this comfy yeah
very yeah Kanye what shoes are [ __ ]
you know our our intern has fake easy
song he's got a whole you know the onion
night from Game of Thrones you watch
that show no I watched like three seas
like the smuggler he knows all the like
back channels that's oh yeah yeah yeah
he could open a fake easy store that's
the guy and he should the guy who has
the brothel no not him
The Onion Knight he's the smuggler I
don't know yeah I saw the whole thing
it's all anyway I saw a guy at the gym
the other day that had on this was
hilarious he had on fake Yeezys you
could tell well the rear matica tells
guys on the side it literally said Kanye
special-edition away you know you can go
on Amazon because I was just so
intrigued cuz well apparently what Ian's
hooked it I'm sorry I Ian's probably
feeling so bad because he's in so deep
but I I'm so intrigued yeah it's
oh man poor hand is why I outed him I'm
so intrigued but it because he finds
like there's hookups yeah so in China
you've got the people that make the the
real Yeezys okay and those same
[ __ ] will make the [ __ ] the
fake on because they do it a little tiny
different so they don't get sued and
then they sell them to people like on
the Silk Road
so there's in-betweens and they sell
them to America and they're not that
cheap you get those for 100 bucks yeah
one like how much can I ask how many
others you're gonna get if you're well
it depends on what the market is like
what do you guys were those run yeah so
these okay so here's the interesting it
sells out right my I'm out they were
like I don't know 200 or something
reasonable sure and when they came out
they shot up and I wanted to get them
but they were like 700 bucks and I was
like I'm not to have they went up to a
thousand and I was like I gotta get them
it's like they going so I paid for him I
paid for them a thousand though what's
the most by the way I've ever paid for
shoes and then the next like month they
rereleased now 400 bucks but that's the
game though man
I did say actually I can I did the same
thing with the supreme bag oh you're
into supreme well we do we have a street
clothing brand okay and supreme as much
of a meme as they are and how ridiculous
has gotten does make awesome [ __ ] yeah
that's kind of the shame of it is that
it's gotten same with Gucci like I love
Gucci and everything they do but it's
like Logan Paul for example is always
wearing Gucci you know lately if I was
good to you I would prohibit sale people
like him maybe can't write like how you
gonna stop that that's funny I do death
threats yeah back there get it get this
stuff well you know Ian said then now
he's gonna burn the shoes I'm sorry and
I'm gonna you know what I should buy a
new pair you should how much $1,000 new
moon then one color
well I mean yellow what is it [ __ ] I
don't know they're cool they're comfy so
do you think that's the the kuda in you
it depends because here's the thing I
will say what most kuda the Dakota so
like the cooter
so so it is it
is kuda to just go get the shoes because
they're popular there is a little bit of
that in me because I can I know that
because when I see a shoe
I think oh that's ugly but then it grows
on me if I see it enough and that's for
sure kuda hmm but it is a cool show so I
think so but thanks yeah and I know a
lot of people a lot of people hate these
I know yeah it's been a whole thing this
year but I like them I think it's fun I
think it's almost like a parody but yeah
but at what point does a thousand dollar
shoe stopping a parody and I hate jokes
ah no I mean I just dropped two hundred
on these these oh yeah the adidas yeah
yeah those are cool can you get it close
up you get a close-up damp really cool
with your shorts and socks I am somewhat
of a fashion icon
psychopath yeah what's going on there
that's a a show you're working on for
YouTube that's that's tough to talk
about I don't know where okay no problem
yeah um here's something I'm super
excited to talk about well I heard you
mention I was watching your hot ones
okay and I heard you mentioned Chris
Gaines yeah and Garth Brooks is like one
of my favorite [ __ ] people in the
world because he's such a goofy guy guys
he's like both a superstar and also like
a cringe lord yes well you see the
[ __ ] when you join Facebook that's
what I want
why Facebook his inaugural Facebook
video for so long I think it's the best
[ __ ] video ever I want to watch we
wanted to talk about this videos been on
I have like a whole list of like great
content I want to talk about that one's
been on there for you a decade that's
not not that that when that came out and
I watched that so my top lip didn't
touch my bottom
you know he's rehearsed it like 30 times
you know I want it to be like I
literally started thinking when is my
topless gonna touch my bottom lip again
like that's how walk around all day just
job Gabe yeah well that was kind of
official was that Facebook was it Chris
Gaines or was it Garth Brooks in that
video who knows but you raise a good
point
let me see first of all let me just for
Tinley you know give you guys the
premise here Garth Brooks you guys all
know Garth Brooks that's Garth Brooks
maybe give a short for the people who
don't know Garth Brooks he's a country
singer he's like the most fit he's like
one of the biggest artists ever do you
listen country music uh no I don't at
all apps doesn't rip you out because it
does trip me out country music is the
most popular genre of music in America
yeah and that just sounds whoa most of
us are idiots right yeah country music
is is and I'm not saying it's not for
smart people as well but it's the
easiest music to listen to if you're a
dummy mm-hmm do you know what I mean
right like it's the easiest music to get
I'm not saying that it doesn't have its
smart songs maybe it does but like you
can understand why a dumb [ __ ]
listens to it well it was a
transformative moment for me when I yeah
all the country fans out there don't
wear a cowboy hat oh don't ever have a
goatee dude if you're in on it if you're
go the whole way bro I don't the whole
way well he only looks like the human
body men of a king of the hill I mean
yeah that's who we're dealing and then
Criss Angel right so I just looked it up
he's the number two best-selling artists
of all time only behind the Beatles this
world there's 300 million people in the
country
okay five million live in LA I had never
my whole life heard almost even a single
country song and then when I realized
when I'm 18 that it's the most popular
that Garth Brooks is the best-selling
artist ever the [ __ ] Beatles over
Michael Jackson over to the
number three is Elvis second I had to be
like real deals and Wow
I had this real like almost
transformative like moment where I was
like oh my god like there's a whole
nother world out there
you just feel yeah also so really big in
Canada
country music really young huh yep
twisted I knew it all along but now I've
got evidence yeah dude
so it's country music is yeah come on
dude
well this guy's a [ __ ] goofball so
this is number two okay this guy sold
this [ __ ] to the whole damn country
people are getting so angry I know these
girls folks fans but I feel like nobody
who's listening to the show the sister
Garth Brooks
somehow the world is that segmented oh
it definitely it is but so so Garth
Brooks who's known for his country music
makes this alter ego Chris Gaines hey
don't even have your first ego Yeah
right make the first one better work on
Garth Brooks right well I mean listen
he's number two true I mean he's not a
[ __ ] Boy Wonder Man but we also liked
it then it would be number yeah true The
Beatles would be like whoo yes
the [ __ ] who there who also very Bend
I don't know I don't you can say [ __ ]
about the Beatles what are they singing
about you know needles I don't know
everything
I not breathe I know I mean it was it
was not let's not let's not do a Garth
Brooks and Beatles I don't I don't
assume like the Beatles are your
favorite band mr. [ __ ] listening party
you know what I don't I don't I don't
not really big on music really my
favorite is to park that's it
that's as far as it goes [ __ ] I like
biggie who would you like biggie I like
to park oh so you still holding onto the
garage yeah I like to park no no no yeah
I don't I like to party
people say Tupac or biggie it's like I
like I'm both you can like Ambo I like
to and biggie was I mean he was a great
rapper he was a great you know he his
flow was [ __ ] amazing
come on stop listening to music in the
nineties
yeah like like like here's the other
thing Big E wrapped about his there were
stories they weren't how he was very
much the story it wasn't it wasn't it
wasn't necessarily about his life sure
to parks [ __ ] was about his life and
that [ __ ] I thought was awesome well I
am a huge Tupac VIN
oh I'm not gonna discount Tupac I mean
he's he's got all the hits and much like
Garth Brooks they have a lot in common
yeah every just when I say Tupac the
first thing comes to mind is king of the
hill over here I don't know but yeah
that Facebook thing when it happened I
don't know if I put up a video make it
fun of it really I sent it you don't
listen music I kind of go go back to
that I mean that's just round of strange
yeah you don't ever listen to music I
mean I listen to hip-hop but who's your
favorite artists these days these days I
don't know I'm not that passionate about
it well there's no one right yeah okay
like people I don't know okay I'm like
like like I like like Jay Cole's [ __ ]
awesome yeah you like Kendrick I mean I
Kendricks fine I know just what it's
interesting you prefer a cold yeah over
Kendrick air um J Cole fans rejoice um
Kendrick is like Kendrick the reason why
I'm not a hundred percent sold on
Kendrick is because he doesn't rap in
the voice that he talks which is ah
which is like he does like this kind of
[ __ ] you know whereas like J Cole he's a
lot of times yeah he does yeah but but
but that's one of the reasons why I I
don't I like that
I like the authentic right this is who I
am you know Ryan and park would be like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] that and then come off
and be like so we doing this [ __ ]
interview you're like oh that's how he
talks yeah dude I mean you like you're
you're a fan I can tell you're a fan a
very much a fan of authenticity yeah
yeah that's what I like yeah I mean you
have this whole thing you've talked
about on your podcasts about
if you're being disrespectful yeah
actually being respect because your beat
your your respecting a person enough to
do what you want to do even though make
frankly their line or like if I were to
put my feet up on the table I'm
respecting you enough to be me and if
I'm like put take your [ __ ] feet off
yeah what the [ __ ] wrong with you I
would take them down because it's your
place ultimately but because but but you
are welcome too much yeah I know I
understand but like I I wouldn't think
you'd care but but my point is I'm me
being me allowing myself to be feel
comfortable around you is like the most
intimate [ __ ] that's true so if I put my
feet up on your table I feel very
comfortable with you guys right and I'm
not it's not like I'm saying like oh you
guys are so lucky I'm comfortable around
you it's just it's just make it makes us
it makes me feel close to you it's like
when I make fun of people and people are
like what are you talking [ __ ] like I'm
not dude like my whole family growing up
whenever we grew when we're growing up
all we did was bust on each other that's
all we did all day long my mom my dad my
brother my uncle's my aunt like we would
make fun of it that's how we showed love
and like so when people are like hey man
why are you making fun of me which
happens every now and then you're like
what did I it's like giving you a hug
like literally interesting in my mind
and I get that that's not like that for
everybody I think that's different
upbringing so I yeah I'm sense of did
that but to me it's like if if you are
comfortable enough to be you that's the
most respect you can give to me
interesting there's truth to that do I
think I [ __ ] honestly sound like a
cult leader for real well that's well I
I wonder if Garth I wonder how God feels
about that statement you can join us and
to return back to uh we never watch it
because we have yeah we have to watch
this yeah but anyway that you can tell
what a [ __ ] goofball he is oh you're
sure with this dime-store you know
either either picture is ridiculous yeah
he looks like a [ __ ] thumb man look
at his face [ __ ] it's weird because
country like couldn't be cool it could
be yeah some of it probably is I don't
know
probably these corny the the kind of
country I know it was just like twangy
and yeah all about you know there was
that one that was so popular I [ __ ]
hate it was about I'm a little drunk and
I need you now you remember that one the
lyrics were so is there every kind of
song is like let me I [ __ ] saw you
once and you're like and then they're
like out of my head so you know what I
want to do I want to read you the first
of all it's okay
I mean 250 million that's too many yeah
oh that's to me actually was expecting
more to be frank but I I heard this on
every [ __ ] where for a long-ass time
yeah I've heard it's a quarter after one
I'm all alone and I need you now said I
wouldn't call but I'm lost all control I
need you now another shot of whiskey
can't stop looking at the door wishing
you come sweep in my way you know what
here it is I'm a little drunk and I need
you now that I don't know what that
really Bob that's perfect
I'm a little to the wrong it's like it's
like can you find a more poetic way to
say that said I wouldn't call but I've
lost all control I don't know what it is
about this line it drove me crazy I'm a
little drunk and I need you now I like
that that drove you crazy cuz she's not
even actually drunk just so I'm a little
drunk [ __ ] get a hold of your line you
know what that is that's a [ __ ] bro
right there I'm drunk I need you now
[ __ ] out of here I realized that it's
not no I'll acknowledge that too no no
it honestly it is as bad as you thought
it and I agree with you it's saying some
guy who plays foosball would say all
right I'm a little drunk that's what
it's so pedestrian yeah that's what they
love a little drunk I need you now right
up down and and get off the foosball to
you want to get together sometime and do
endless preview a kanye album listening
fly to Miami this is just this we're
gonna have to break how many of uses a
half well I think it's been ripped like
how many it's a really shitty or
reupload I've been 150,000 bucks so let
me so by the way let's just say look at
the time
yeah let's just say before we even start
this Facebook had been up and running
for 25 years yeah this wasn't like no
there's nothing groundbreaking but just
imagine this guy is more famous to
Michael Jack Arthur Brooks has
definitely said before something like
this like I don't know how much milk is
what is it $15 and you're like no you're
not you're not you're not salt of the
earth yeah yeah here's here's $50 go get
a carton of milk like that's what he's
done and you're like oh that okay you
know what I'm curious about that I want
to check really fast mmm Garth Brooks
net worth what's this guy 300 million
could be worth more a lot of milk okay
that's like 10 10 gallons of milk
so anyway lit amazing a shake again fair
so anyway this is his first facebook
upload we've we've introduced it another
where's my mouse button for Christ's
sake okay here we go well I guess it's
official
we're now on Facebook you know he
rehearse that little chuckle like we
know what the [ __ ] this is about wanna
[ __ ] jump off a bridge there were the
thing is he's trying so hard to be
authentic but it comes off like you
can't rehearse a chuckle like it's so
[ __ ] hot but he is official we're now
on baby wasn't had to be authentic and
[ __ ] 40 years old why he doesn't know
what it's like yeah we're now on
Facebook look we're now on Facebook I
really wasn't sure about this at the
start but then a friend of mine said
something they just made all kinds of
sense no he didn't
she said also just publicly that dude
it's it's almost like a dating video
this ad this is like the saddest
dating video ever you'd be like this guy
is probably on a sex offender list oh
yes I like that it's something they just
made all kinds of sense
she said think of it more as a
conversation I like that all right he's
like it's so calculated pause smile
chuckle I like I like to think that he
forgot about what he was talking about
thought of it like what you could see
him register but I'm already finding out
my own so it's wiping the walls out
between you and me and I really like
that
I'm dude the way he drilled that I
really like that it's like damn it's
honestly very weird it is flirting yeah
he's trying to [ __ ] me also or is
somebody he's holding so close to his
face has no shirt below this and he's in
a hotel room apparently who says so oh
yeah yeah yeah I really like that
I love the [ __ ] guy being the walls
out between he's a human thumb look at
his face he's like just a thumb with
features me and I really like that I
really like that really like that it
allows us into each others worlds or I
guess in my case hotel room well I think
about things I want to post I want to
post cool stuff slick stuff neat stuff
but most stuff I'm gonna post is gonna
be raw stuff like this this is arroz it
gets baby on the hundredth try Oh
kind of makes my skin crawl
no it's weird it might be it might be
the greatest video on it might be the
watching this again there's so much
going on might be it should have more
views than I think they were finding
that it was the first thing you said the
facebook video and like because I no one
talks about
I know not like yeah I mean it
definitely got a lot of use because it's
him but like not enough it not yeah well
why wasn't this is what he's no see yeah
this is they should be what he's known
for
yeah well because that's what I said
means that when you bring up logbook
anytime anyone brings up card Brooks
this is what like Mark Zuckerberg
Facebook guy you know Chris Kane yeah
slick stuff slick stuff but can only
Paul Olli pause raw stuff like I like
that I really like it's just who I am
let's go back and kind of enjoy this
whole last cuz it's just who I he's a
girl alright but most of stuff I'm gonna
post is gonna be raw stuff like this
this is just who I am
so this is truly a conversation can I
say let the conversation begin all right
now I'm taking off my pants I'm putting
my dick up on the webcam yeah it sounds
to me like you're not ready to let the
conversation begin it just not yeah well
don't push back also did it even begin
after it's just very the fact that like
a guy can be thinking this is the thing
that fascinates me the most out of for
humans for since my I've been an adult
this is the thing that's fascinating the
most there's also my my number one
nightmare to be the way you think you're
not being to come across he thinks he's
being authentic yeah it's the exact
opposite is happening yeah
interest you watch that and you think oh
that's and he does that's my biggest
nightmare is to walk into a rolly
understand what you mean yeah but do you
think that he'd like he's this is
clearly extremely rare
yes so you think it's possible for
someone to almost be have that duality
of mine sure it's possible yeah
definitely he could be doing that yeah
maybe he is but either way it sucks
either way it's [ __ ] so funny and
crazy yeah like come on dude yeah how I
I I don't know maybe because I'm a
comedian and like I you have to let
people kind of know who you are for it
to work unless you're gonna do like a
character which I don't do but like you
have a podcast you know you know you're
yeah yeah you can't you're not some
corny radio host like that that's what
he is
you know and it's I wonder do you think
he drinks Lacroix definitely drinks coke
and he definitely if he does good he's
gonna drink sparkling water it's for
sure that high-end he's drinking soda
with cherry syrup in it with a big-ass
green straw yep yep yeah oh yeah he's
done really like that oh I think glass I
like that a thin straw oh really I
really like that kind of gotta get I
hear it man this is it yeah I almost
want it and I want to recreate it I want
to upload this to my youtube channel
unedited I think I think I did this and
uploaded it are you serious you did you
recreated it I know I real I know I said
in the video to your oh I know I sent it
to Joe okay let's see what I think about
the Bryan Callen I don't know if I ever
uploaded it because it wasn't you but
somehow it's just five months ago it's
not even that long ago oh yeah so
somebody found well that's why I guess
it's official what we're now a tempered
I really wasn't sure
about this at the start so friend of
mine it's act too bad and I will say
this operations like I I didn't write it
down
I watched it so many times from pash
that I did it I don't know this is from
I remember I remember it's a straight
feeling an authenticity no I really like
that I can't believe for I need to
acknowledge that this is for a while
this is pretty insane that this exists
you're in a hotel right yeah I'm
immersed well I guess it's official
on Facebook you know I really wasn't
sure about that opossums birth they've
been a friend of mine said something
that made all kinds of sense okay she
said just think of it as a conversation
I like that know what I'm already
noticing myself is that it's wiping away
the walls of communication between you
and me okay
really like that that line is an
invitation to [ __ ] yes
that's a that's a [ __ ] that's a let's
[ __ ] what did I think Facebook was
yeah yeah everybody can see this yeah
for all right each others worlds or in
my case my hotel room post what a post
cool stuff slick stuff neat stuff but
I'm probably gonna end up posting raw
stuff like this cuz it's Who I am
yeah well I guess if this is a
conversation then I say let the
conversation begin
that was that was I gotta say I'm blown
away
yeah here we are right now that's weird
why our own video that we're live right
now broad news being suggested Wow well
that's strange
yeah dude that's so that was such a good
yeah you did like laughs we were like
hey let's bring this up but not let
every we did it meditate that I'm so
glad that we were both found common
ground on that yeah I can't think of one
Garth Brooks song not one uh you know I
guess I can't either
here God you do rope it in the wind or
was that someone else who roping in the
wind
there's that some I better look out damn
he's kind of he's kind of looking a
little porky piggish right now does that
mean is that racist yes well no I just
think that when you get older I feel
like everyone's just kind of gets bigger
what do you think about that in the
don't see cowboy how it's just killer
like what are you doing
that's pretty killer though I gotta
start doing that I've realized like yeah
the cowboy the bowtie the cowboy look is
pretty cool you like it well do you like
well it looks cool on some people on
some people like people wanted to [ __ ]
him I mean he was a sex I come this man
right here is a sex icon right Harry was
fresh-faced my ever whatever I will
never wear a button-down with no collar
that's like what are you doing
that's why you get your hair cut that's
what he'll never be the number two
selling artist yeah yep
but what I am curious about let's just
hop back on over YouTube cuz that I like
doing this where you can type the artist
and sort by most popular so let's see
what kind of there we are again for
Christ's sake it's weird
live now Garth Brooks filter view count
oh okay yeah that's it I guess he's just
he's been around too long yes that is
what it is I've been around too long
31:34 Millions is yeah because I [ __ ]
migos has four trillion yeah
Gangnam style is more popular than Garth
Brooks apparently on YouTube yeah what
some are those like reuploads too cuz
look at the channels it's not even yeah
this is the social the you're not afraid
I mean am i tripping or is this the same
guy that uploaded your no on video no
okay let's get out Wow let's get out of
this course that was amazing
I just want to talk about cars I'm being
Frank yeah and I see you have your feet
up thank you for doing now no problem
problem you we kind of talked about this
about how you hate Coachella you hate
the listening parties you hate the Woo's
yeah is there anything on your top on
your list of things that you hate do you
kind of want you've been thinking about
you want to talk about a little bit um
something that's kind of hit you lately
recently new Anoosh thing I don't know I
I I talk about it all the time on my and
it's not that I hate it it's just that
it hurts me but yeah yeah Rosie the
wrong way or whatever but I don't know
the last thing was like the listening
party like when I heard that oh come on
what's going on in I don't want to put
you on the spot if they easy are good
yeah in turn he he was at one of those
listening parties no en can you grab the
mic yeah that was so in which listening
party were you at kids see ghosts oh
really
what kids see Cody that was in LA right
yeah how was it when Troy it was it a
great transcendental experience
transcendental what the [ __ ] are you
talking about so you get there you park
right like a [ __ ] [ __ ] you put the
ticket you get you get a ticket right to
park read you park on the street I
parked like in this dirt field that is
pretty bohemian mm-hmm god I wish it was
again a place where you were just like
yeah I just have had to find his mind
what I gotta say it was super
pretentious the whole parking situation
because they made us Park and then put
us on a shuttle in the shuttle drone
literally for 30 seconds we drove 30
seconds down a road and then they kicked
us out of the shuttle and like all right
we're here so Ian you left that you
omitted that detail there like you were
here
we are and they're like why not we could
have it here that gives you [ __ ] so just
play and and and there was a bonfire
right in yeah yeah big you know why
there's a bonfire you know why there's a
bonfire because it distracts you from
what a bunch of [ __ ] idiots you guys
are because if there was a bonfire you'd
be like what the [ __ ] are we doing here
that's not a bonfire because a listening
party is not something right it's a
bonfire you need a focal point it's more
of like there was a full buffet though
there was so it's a party parties in the
title anything else any other music well
they did play their music right yeah
it's a short one 20 minutes because it's
a short yeah in did you sense because it
was such a short album was heard any
disappointment in the crowd when they're
like oh man I will say the crowd and Dan
can attest to this I was dancing my ass
off but everyone else was like too cool
for yeah that's annoying
yeah even with the bonfire yeah it was
like it was for most of the people there
it seemed like it was more of a photo op
yeah that's it see that's kuta Hakuna
Matata
[Laughter]
crazy man why'd you go so why'd you go
then what made it what made you want to
go music Anya I'm like a die-hard he's a
super fan guy and I love Kanye yeah
gotcha I feel like he's gonna get ripped
forever since I exposed the fake easy
yeah we don't have to keep saying them
when I said fake easy where is that
something that you were trying to keep
secret not to keep like bringing it up
but I'm just genuinely hears that people
just don't bring it you know I didn't
quite catch that can you say the words
fake Easy's like maybe seven more times
yeah I mean you wear the fake easy to
the listing no
real [ __ ] there's a video of a
fan doing that trying to get him to sign
oh and Kanye looks some eyes and goes
those are fake no way so Kanye problem
so even Khan you okay because the fakes
look good Kanye has that well he makes
it yeah yeah it looks identical except
like a couple stitches or no but he
knows no way ela would know cuz you
would know if someone copied your joke
you would know I know but you came up
with it okay yeah you're probably right
yeah wow yeah wow yeah I like the stance
you've taken them he's not budging Ian
where do you get fake Easy's it's a
process
III frankly was intrigued by it all
right maybe we look I made them that's
the bet I was the best my jaw dropped
like the Garth Brooks video I went I
can't help it sometimes I walk by these
people and I go everyone's getting out
of control but you know talking about
kinda Matata we were at pot you know
this club hobbies I've heard about it
yeah we were gonna we were hanging out
our post Malone was at the Hollywood
Bowl last night he's a friend of ours
and we went with him afterwards to this
club Poppy's and with like the whole
entourage and I'm thinking oh yeah cause
he was on your podcast yeah and so I'm
thinking this can be interesting I don't
really go of clubbing
it's so [ __ ] small dude poppy it's
yeah the club is so weird the room I
mean the room were in is so I this must
be like illegally packed
Wow it was so funny name is probably
especially packed because he was there
yeah oh I'm sure I'm sure
but like there's people outside lined up
I'm trying to get out yeah there's not
even really an exit for people but
there's a lot of sure legal yeah yeah
but what I what I saw outside was was a
lot of people like I just actually don't
know why
wouldn't want to be in there except post
law why because it's so [ __ ] packed
why does he want to be in there because
he's the center of attention he's their
seller right yeah I guess though see
that's the thing like I guess he parties
right like so if your party it's a
different thing
I don't so like when I'm at I'm a
comedian and at my show and granted
they're not as big as [ __ ] post
Malone shows but like after that I don't
want to go somewhere you're done he's a
young man but he's like you're an
old-ass 38 year old man yeah yeah I
sometimes I forget because I'm 33 and
that's kind of [ __ ] like I probably
shouldn't even be talking anymore
actually one thing that I learned about
you that did intrigue me why is that
well first of all let me say that I love
your bit about the drunk girl dry
heaving and I'm like oh this guy's
obviously spent a lot of time yeah you
know but you don't actually you don't
drink you don't use drugs
you don't smoke cannabis no and I will
say that have you ever tried these and
now I made preface this by saying I
always have to answer this question four
or five times in a row because they
don't I've literally never been drunk
I've never done I've never smoked weed
never done any drugs never drank well
one of my favorite really ever surprises
but like more one of my favorite artists
Frank Zappa who's like the nuttiest guy
of all time and the guy you think was on
acid all yeah I'm was completely
straight edge I refused to believe work
with people who use drugs oh wow really
I I think it's really cool but I'm just
curious what's the theory behind it so I
don't I I first of all when I was young
young okay there's a few things I don't
like to do the thing that everybody's
doing immediately I'm like wait why the
[ __ ] is everybody doing that that's got
to be weird okay so when he was sort of
drinking in high school and [ __ ] oh why
is everybody doing this I'm gonna take a
beat
maybe I'll [ __ ] do it later okay so
there was that then there was also when
I used to watch like the old Batman
shows with Adam West and [ __ ] when
with like penguin and Joker would gas
people that would scare the [ __ ] out of
me so I would equate like being drunk to
another altered state of mind to where
like like laughing gas was so as a kid I
was also a little bit scared of it after
that I grew up and I have a thing where
I don't ever do anything until I regret
that I haven't done it which means I
didn't lose my virginity until I thought
oh I should have had sex that one time
and I missed out mm-hmm right because
then I know I actually want to do it and
same goes with drinking and drugs and I
just have never felt like I missed out
you don't feel come about I never ever
was curious about it I never felt like
oh man everyone was high I should have
done it to the other night really anyone
I do feel that way I will do it huh I
just I'm not saying I'll never do it
it's impressive as [ __ ] that you have
never even had a beer I mean that's
weird I mean it's good for you that [ __ ]
boys it's healthy yes all boys and I
know I have an addictive personality for
sure now being older what are you
[ __ ] oh yeah what are you well okay
working out like like that's a good yeah
yeah but I mean stand-up comedy dude I
mean you know and it's a good things
addiction that's like a negative comment
no no but like the obsessive nature of
it and there's like I've worked out
today I could go again you have any do
you have like okay vices now yeah what's
the vice I mean come on your addictive
personality I mean I drink so much
[ __ ] come on hey that's good for you
mm-hm
remember not as much as I impersonating
Garth Brooks that's what I do have three
Glen Lea stop you say you tell me you
never did that at least a hundred times
before you film that that's cool I don't
have a problem with drugs but usually
when I do them I regret it really just
because you feel shitty the next day and
you're like no more here's the other
thing
it's bundle some of my best experiences
some of the finest times abroad but
here's the other thing though uh I feel
shitty in the morning a lot you know
anyway yeah yeah you know that means
yeah yeah like you know when you wake up
and you're like oh what I do last night
and you're like no nothing you're like
oh then why am I in pain and why do I
have to [ __ ] so at least you have an
excuse when you drink and
sighs and you still wake up no once I
went started doing like the past year
I've been exercising really a lot
because I wake up like that and I don't
exercise always it's a long better when
you had held ours we beard I'll tell you
what I'm almost there I've been thinking
about Serena it says for at least three
years well in the next eight nine ten
years when you should give it a shot
well I have a heart attack you'll think
back now you'll be old you'll be the 40
oh yeah I mean I basically will be in
silence yeah that much well gonna
exercise dude no I do like like circuit
training like I just like I'll do like
like I'll run and I'll do sprints and
then I'll lift the little weights a lot
of body resistance stuff and the trainer
I have had a trainer but you know I kind
of adopted my own [ __ ] now you learned
some of them you know a lot I also and I
like doing it and you know I like to
sweat and I like to I like to spend an
hour not checking my phone yeah
otherwise I'll just you know I mean so
yeah but but you don't like it until you
get out okay how long did it take you
until you liked it and how it was it
gruelling up until that point it's
[ __ ] hard in the beginning man also
have you have you ever been in a guy who
exercises I've gone probably at most
maybe like six months of being like okay
so yeah I was there cuz if you've never
done it it's like really [ __ ] on the
only thing I did was swim oh my can
that's that's hard yeah yeah yeah it's
it's um I don't know man I just like it
I like to sweat and be exhaust myself
see if I could do more than next time
you know well being healthy and looking
good is [ __ ] yes that also and and
and also it's like if I'm gonna be on
camera it's my job yes I tell myself
that too as I eat a hamburger yeah every
[ __ ] time for hamburgers are the best
do you have a problem with food like do
you like see now that you're exercising
a lot just diet something you think
about I do yeah um I I'm basically like
really good all day and then at night is
like where I'm like
you let it go yeah that's great and and
I and I try to I try to forget you
forgive myself about it I try to not
like be like because I don't want to be
some look here's what I want to be if
you guys get a pizza I don't want to be
the guy that's like nah give me a slice
dude you're an [ __ ] if you're like
completely you get a pizza you to [ __ ]
important pizza yeah you know so uh you
know your your slice skipper no I agree
with like the don't be such an extreme
to like ruin a party exactly yeah okay
like the vegetarian theory of like I
won't [ __ ] touch it I was like and
when my brother went vegetarian if my
mom still cooked something in in the pot
which you can but let's say there's
beans you want to touch the bean so it's
like okay so you're asking her now to
cook a whole so that's when I'm like
well just I wish you may compromise
that's all I wish you enabled me more
mmm-hmm yeah no it's not maybe I don't
know you guys just yeah was she I wish
she enabled me more we just ate a
breakfast burrito and today it's not
enough so we're getting we're about to
wrap okay but I have a couple of things
I want to ask you first we just kind of
become a thing with our with our show
here so this is something that we happen
to talk a lot about and I find it
fascinating because it's so private and
everyone has their own different
approach how do you wipe your ass how do
you wholly nup do use baby wipes given
bidet
you're asking me about a lot of stuff
that I already have severe opinions
about and that's great I like this it's
like I prepared well how do you wipe
first of all how do you do it well the
way that I do it is I love baby wipes
changed my [ __ ] life girl because you
go dry dries a whole mess it's just not
feasible it's not it doesn't cut it you
try to clean you know it's like
sandpaper you ever believe from your
[ __ ] from wiping too much yes
isn't that the [ __ ] worse you see
yeah it's bad it's better baby wipe you
go and dry you end what you called a
[ __ ] day now there's been a whole
debate about our baby wipes
that flushable baby wipes are they
actually flushable now that's a debate
we have a lot of people say it's
destroying sewage systems okay so and
then there's a there's also a bait
because I want a thorough answer from
you you go from the front you go from
the back back see I am an unusual breed
I go from the front a lot of people they
reject I never knew it is so like that's
what I got at you're been hearing that
no I lift the balls yeah I know but you
bring it closer to your bowl my balls
are not that will you lift it up you
don't like at most I'll go like at most
I'll go like halfway up the chod it
sensed like so much more uncomfortable
just to be safe back I don't get this
yes weird it's like are you sitting or
are you standing yes you [ __ ] go
under the balls yeah imagine what you
look like
people generally aren't watching me
imagine how you look like like this
isn't a sexy and pretty like Oh what do
you got when you go but I'm just saying
a lot I get a lot of pushback but I
think I like look I you lift you cup the
balls the thing is like I'm like you can
be quite comfortable don't you that I
don't get about this doesn't your arm
touch the bowl what is nice guys know
you raise up a little bit more but what
I don't get is if you don't get it all
you're pushing god this is gross I
wishing [ __ ] closer to your dick what is
that like what the whole thing is just
about how close is [ __ ] to my but also
I'm not it's not so much that you're
bringing [ __ ] closer I mean you're
cleaning out your [ __ ] are you
bringing [ __ ] closer to your head
[Laughter]
okay so all right so all right so I
first of all I'll tell you right up
right straight up [ __ ] baby wipes I I
don't like baby wipes
why because I'm not ending with a wet
[ __ ] dude it does its moist it's not
a baby way so here's the deal I had a
fissure or whatever once years ago a
flasher yeah which is like you know
that's why you bleed out of your butt
that's just a cut on your yes right
because future sounds like you're at
your you know bro laughs no no that's
different that's not you prolapsed
didn't do that guy but so the doctor was
like just use baby western in a hill he
was like okay so I use baby wipes and
then I was in an apartment complex at
this time and my toilet would get so
[ __ ] clogged and I go down and I'd be
like hey guys my toilets clogged and
they're like oh we're using flush
shovels I don't mean I don't know [ __ ]
your whole world up so and then they
were like they were like we found that
you're using baby wire and they were
like you can't use those in this
apartment um except I was like no get
better toilets like that my daughter for
me uses [ __ ] man I get that far but you
know what that you're supposed to do
technically throw them in the garbage
you're not sure [ __ ] oh it's so so look
so so I don't like I don't like baby
wipes I don't do them it feels gross do
you look after every white okay no I
used to and I started taking this thing
which I guess is psyllium husk or
whatever the [ __ ] are like Metamucil I
think dude I do white but you don't have
to what you do you take a wiping
supplement no no no no no it's it's it's
it's for your bowel movements and it
congeals at all why
Metamucil did this happen to time up at
all with when you started like
exercising no I basically asked my
friend about it I was like dude I redoes
if you how do many times do you wipe and
he was like - Wow hey man what yeah you
have an [ __ ] yeah and he was like
yeah I take this to their houses like Oh
cuz I would write like 30 times
okay and yeah no that's fine I'd be like
yeah
that's how you end up with a Fisher so
so I take this dude you got I wipe once
and I look and I'm like do I even have
to wipe and I just wiped but another
time for good measure dude it's like you
say you don't need the baby wipe
you don't need butter today I mean I
wipe obviously but you don't need the
wet one no you don't and your shits just
go boom dude you should take the cilium
house for real so let me ask you I know
you started taking it yeah and what how
long after you started taking to do
degrees and ever since then take it
every day yes it changes your life huh
I'll show you what I take out I'll send
it to you that why is that not that
revolutionary I don't know see Liam husk
yep
do you see how much you see you're like
oh this is a weird conversation to have
but this is where you learned the most
about life I mean it helps you more than
[ __ ] what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do you know people are like ah
you know
motivation policies in the world you can
you can change your bowel movement right
so that's within our grasp as of now and
literally I wipe a lot it takes a lot it
doesn't if you take psyllium husk dude
even if you eat awful yeah bro I would
have to that's [ __ ] crazy
35 times what you I could wipe I just
keep wiping this [ __ ] was like well do
now do you go in deep because you can
there's different levels of clean like
some people are happy they go surface on
they do like a wax on wax off I clean
yeah I clean - I clean I'm not gonna
walk around with anything I basically
finger my [ __ ]
it sounds unnecessary I don't I don't
[ __ ] around I don't [ __ ] around either
man that's right that's why I take a
supplement for it yeah well I'm on that
yeah I'm gonna check that out and I
don't picture what this dialogue is
really yeah in Ewing cuz Tom we had on
recently and he was like the bidet
changed my life and the bidet I don't
get because you're squirting water at
your [ __ ] I've got an area [ __ ]
that makes everything worse yeah I would
think so the baby whoops too wet I mean
you're squirting love with the water so
he was showing us this luxury b-day we'd
like a dryer too
inter eyes your fanatical noodles the
blows hot air and your [ __ ] I mean I
guess I better unit here you better hope
you got all this [ __ ] if I'm you're
blowing hot air out under like this yeah
that's how I end every [ __ ] yeah all
right that was good that was fruitful
Celia ma I got it yeah I wonder if we
should make our own brand my face on it
I'll give you a percentage psyllium husk
this is important let me bold and
italicize this okay i'ma underline it as
well mines Metamucil and it's orange
it's like an orange container that I use
psyllium Hut here let me pull it up
because I think people here actually
have a lot to benefit from this some of
you guys will use it because I'm talking
about it on the podcast and you'll
[ __ ] think about me every time you
take a [ __ ]
there you go man whatever works this is
it apparently it's like a grain or some
[ __ ] you know so whatever it is it
[ __ ] works great in the [ __ ]
I just eat this I don't know I actually
don't know is it just fiber dude you can
there's no it's not my bro it's not well
I don't know if that is but but the but
the the the thing that I take is not I
mean maybe there's you know I'm sure
there's stuff in it that's like that but
all I know is it [ __ ] works dude all
right I'm on it if it works for me then
it works for anyone let me put it that's
what I would that's what I thought
and I was like I will see and it worked
I want to snort that [ __ ] yeah would
that help I think it would yeah anything
kind of I get it in all your years
orifices so here's our last question
this one we've been doing for a long
time okay if you don't have a response
that's perfectly fine I don't either but
somehow you just never know what to
expect
okay do you have any ghost stories or
paranormal experiences in your life no I
dine with me neither I don't either
and and I just don't I don't be a Bobby
Leon right he's got like a million of
them yeah why why is happened to him
he's after me once that's what I've
known all the same people don't yeah
it's just I want to believe that you
know I'm open to it
sure yeah a one-time one time I was I
had a we went we went to [ __ ] cute
I went one time I went to uh we had like
a kitten like Malachy we were my buddies
backyard we wanted to go sleep outside
the backyard we took a tent out there
went into the wooded area and in the
middle of the night we were laughing in
the middle of the night somebody we
heard a low lady's voice and she was
like could you guys keep it down we're
trying to sleep and we were like how the
[ __ ] where did she come from
it's his backyard we don't know who it
was but it was a person just a weird
thing that happened but we was scared
the [ __ ] out of us yeah that's as good
as it goes stories I could yeah yeah
that's great you know
well great it we did it I want to say
thank you huge huge fan and I appreciate
that I want to urge everybody to first
of all go check out congratulations
yes I'll actually open these these are
oh yeah we have a little we have a
little anthrax I gave them to people and
I want definitely go watch
congratulations yeah it's on YouTube on
your YouTube channel
there's philia definitely go to Chris
D'Elia dot-com slush tour yes and get
some [ __ ] pig gaming to your thing
and you're not ok it's an do not at any
any reason say woo during it
yeah yeah this is the old enough I get
that it be known that ethan klein has
demonstrated an exceptional ex you're an
elder of my colton commitment to living
and spreading baby ship in the world and
honoring the congratulations show with
the consent of daddy Chris D'Elia
this person henceforth carries the
status of elder yeah and there's your
pin there to prove it and there another
thing this is nice paper this isn't like
a guy yeah we don't this is after like
we spend money this is real paper
it's signed yeah daddy signed it and
there's a little pacifier that says
elder which kind of is contradictory
isn't it yes and upset yeah but I buy it
yeah I'm in there you go it looks good
on you well me about my pin on so guys I
had I had a lot of fun yeah how do you
cam yeah this was great
it almost looks like a UFO and way too
it does which is to play on the whole
court cold ship that's a good point
am I still in you're still you're all
right you're all right yeah you guys
could drop the [ __ ] good anyway guys
I hope you had as much of a blast as I'm
so challenged I can't I don't know how
to do this but really I'm making it my
stage oh my god I'm covered in dandruff
well don't look it's okay I don't think
that we didn't know and um let me just
say that I really like that boy you know
this this space I like that this podcast
I really like those guys go check out
Chris on everything he's doing goddammit
thank you all so much for watching we
will be back next week with I don't know
who mm-hmm I mean who's that a good
pitch oh yeah he'll is not gonna be here
my family oh wow
all those are flight it's 15 hours it's
17 hours some ways 15 hours the short
way oh yeah Wow
don't remind me well have fun mm-hmm I
save and God bless you
that's it the show is over thanks guys
thanks for watching everybody
we'll see you next time on the h3
podcast it's expirience you can end it
now
[Music]
[Music]